Will the Last Man on Earth
escape the TV scifi comedy curse?
I have the answer--
--on this week's episode
of Angry Nerd!
First, your comments.
AT Jamin writes,
“Can you talk about”
“Netflix's upcoming”
“Legend of Zelda show?”
Hey, alls I know
for sure about it
is that it's
going to be better
than the Zelda CD-i game.
What was up with that?
How was THAT a thing?
So Will Forte's new series
Last Man on Earth
is like a funny take
on I Am Legend...
but with no
vampire zombies.
Now, I'm a sucker
for the “Man Alone”
subgenre of scifi,
because it can be
bleak AND funny
at the same time.
Like Charlton Heston
in Omega Man
lipsynching along
with a movie he's seen a hundred times.
Or when Bruno Lawrence
cracks up and
declares himself planetary president
in The Quiet Earth.
Or that episode of
Twilight Zone where
Burgess Meredith
is finally alone
with all of the books
that he's eager to read...
and he breaks his glasses.
“THAT’S NOT FAIR…”
“THAT’S NOT FAIR AT ALL!”
Ugh, that scene
always makes me want
to duct tape my glasses
to my noggin.
Anyway, I really like the dry,
laughtrack-free humor of
Last Man on Earth!
You can tell it was produced by
the genius comedy team Lord and Miller,
who made 21 Jump Street
and the Lego Movie.
BY THE WAY,
HOW EFFED UP IS IT
THAT LEGO MOVIE
DIDN'T GET AN OSCAR NOM?!
Last Man on Earth
is also a nice change of pace
from most American scifi comedy series.
Think about it--
the biggest hits are always
the broadest,
silliest,
lowest common denominator-iest stuff!
Alf,
My Favorite Martian,
Mork & Mindy,
Third Rock from the Sun...
I mean, none of them
are that different
from a Family Matters episode
where Urkel makes a bizarre contraption.
The Brits have a much higher class
of scifi comedy--
I think it's partly the influence
of Doctor Who, which could never
really take itself TOO seriously
because the effects were so laughable.
The UK gave us
Hitchhiker's Guide to the Galaxy
by Doctor Who alum Douglas Adams,
Red Dwarf,
Hyperdrive,
2point4 Children,
Goodnight Sweetheart,
No Heroics…
All worth seeking out.
All light years
beyond Alf.
The closest we get to
gut-busting science fiction on TV
in America
are SyFy channel monster movies.
I don’t care what you say--
Sharknado is overrated!
it's all about
MegaShark versus Crocasaurus.
Mwah!
But I demand to see
more American TV scifi
that is hilarious ON PURPOSE!
Annnnnnd...cut!
So was that last take okay?
Do I need to redo it?
Hey, where'd everyone go?
Hello?
Helloooo?
They're all gone!
I'm the last man on Earth!
Oh, at last!
I finally have the time
to read my backlog of comics
with no interruptions!
I can finally--
can finally--
Not fair!
It's not fair!
IT'S NOT FAIR!!!!
Hey, I don’t care if
the Korean taco truck is going by--
don’t leave me alone on this set again!
What do you think of
Last Man on Earth?
And what's your favorite
scifi comedy series,
American or otherwise?
Let me know in the comments,
subscribe to the Wired channel,
and click on these other videos
to watch more of my rants!
If you don't click,
those other versions of me
will just be stuck sitting there--
alone!
Cut off from humanity!
Gradually driven insane
by the oppressive solitude!
What?
You're STILL not clicking?!
You heartless monster!
How can you live with yourself?
I'll bet your top 10
desert island DVDs
are all Michael Bay movies!